[Music]
that like band Tick Tock build you see
that thing where
uh basically the language they're using
in the bill is any it's something about
like you can't connect with what they
Define and as like a foreign actor right
um
and if you now if you like the bill is
proposing if you use a VPN to utilize a
piece of software that's deemed a
foreign actor they can fine you 250 000
and it's like a federal crime really
something to that tune yeah it's
something really wild and
um this is like the Chinese firewall
yeah yeah it's like yes like the Chinese
firewall but it's like uh it's like the
Patriot Act almost but like on steroids
because it wasn't the Patriot Act
like kind of scan like recording
people's conversations that's how like
it was perceived right yeah yeah so this
was like sort of you know like the
you know
after 9 11 this was like the you know
Panic that domestic terrorism exists but
now I guess this bill
I guess it wouldn't be this on steroids
but this bill almost feels as an
extension of this where it's trying to
provision the government to
be able to go into like all of your
internet-based devices so if they think
for whatever reason that you're part
you're engaging a foreign actor they can
you know without uh
like without not without reason but
without limits
investigate [__] your ring camera
your [__] Google home your iPhone
your iCloud they basically are trying to
create it so that they have a back door
to everything and
the people who would be potentially in
charge of this it's just like a random
person that's part of a presidential
cabinet and then they form their own
committee about it so whoever is in
office like they just pick the guy who
has like the keys to the city basically
I hope it's the guy that didn't know
like how a Wi-Fi router worked oh my
home Wi-Fi
I I got with people like I okay when I
saw that clip I love that [__] but I
wasn't sure like I know Congressman can
be stupid but I wasn't sure if that was
old people not knowing technology or was
this like them asking obvious questions
to try to get the guy into like I gotcha
so I I like I only saw those clips so I
was you know not that I give a [__]
about judging Congressman but I wasn't
immediately like oh this guy's a [__] I
was like can you bring that up Luke home
Wi-Fi network
only if the user turns on the Wi-Fi I
I'm sorry I may not understand that so
if I have a tick tock app on my phone
right and my project on my home I love
when they ask a question that's so so
stupid that it's like doesn't even
really makes you can't really form an
answer to it yeah
because it does the access the home
Wi-Fi yeah what do you mean I don't what
well at the end of this clip doesn't he
ask like then like could could Tick Tock
then access devices on the network like
wasn't that like his big follow-up okay
play it network does tick tock access
that Network
it will have to to access the network to
get connections to the internet if
that's the question is it possible then
that it could access other devices on
that home Wi-Fi network
Congressman that we do not do anything
that is beyond any industry Norms
um I believe the answer to your
customers no it could be technical let
me get back to you okay I'd appreciate
if you can answer that I'd like to
change directions so that that's what I
thought he was trying to do was trying
to get him in a gotcha because like
not that I have a [__] dog in this
race but that to me seemed like
he's like dodging a little bit like oh
yeah we wouldn't do anything that's uh
outside of Industry Norms but it could
you know I'd have to get back to you and
it's like I thought they were trying to
be kind of stupid about it because
they're trying to get him to say no Tick
Tock doesn't do that so then they could
prove that it does or some [__] yeah
yeah yeah but yeah out of context like
the guy's voice isn't helping him either
yeah
if I had my I.T guy coming and he
installed the Wi-Fi I think uh you know
minus Spectrum 5G yeah 8304 yours might
be something different yeah Tick Tock
can access that right yeah can I there's
an iPhone I mean I guess an iPhone can
do that because an iPhone can like yeah
see devices on the network yeah
but I don't I'm not really familiar with
like an iPhone's capabilities to pull
things off like it can see other devices
on the network but
isn't there like a degree of I don't
know interaction like you have to like
like prompt the device to do to get
something else like no idea I just
wonder like I'm genuinely curious
because yeah usually you have to give
permission on the other device yeah but
maybe there's some back door or
something or like
yeah like uh I remember reading
something about like it was like a
morality thing with iPhones where it was
some people kind of refuting Apple's
position that they don't
um
you know oh we like privacy first we
care about privacy but uh they were
talking about how like iOS Engineers are
basically saying that like iPhones don't
need to be connected to the internet to
kind of like geographically Place
themselves and this created a morality
thing where I guess there are certain
engineers at Apple that
can like could figure things out like oh
yeah based on like
the
the frequent like positioning of these
phones like this is clearly like a trap
house or like uh okay you know like you
know people clearly go here to do said
things like
um that's basically people saying that
Apple may not monetize all that but they
definitely have a [__] ton of
information that they could do more with
and that just that just tripped me out
that's pretty interesting yeah
yeah anyway
what's this [__] AI Heavenly fit oh
is this the Pope the Pope's jacket
dude so funny this tricked so many
people
damn a lot of people thought that this
was real
damn
him and Mark Wahlberg dude that jacket
is
the drip got him feeling crazy bruh
killing it my guy
that's another one
a jacket is hard
it's awesome because this [__] is too
good man yeah dude what wait pull it
that looks so real yeah well they're
probably using a reference the like the
just straight reference image and then
yeah iterating on top have you messed
with that at all is this mid Journey
yeah I haven't used the new one oh bro
it's scary the way is it is it Discord
still
um yeah yeah you know it's a dark sorry
I've been I've been offering some kid
Cuddy thoughts this whole time but yeah
me too dude
something that freaked me out was
imagine like a bad actor accessing like
some chat like I was picturing okay when
does chat GPT start selling a license
that you can access all the data like
through an API right
and then I just started thinking like
some [__] freak
hooking that up to some open source
mid-journey type app
and they just make some creepy ass thing
like
you know you upload a picture of someone
you saw in a public place you're like I
thought this person was cute who is this
yeah or like worse like let me see porn
of that person yeah
like that's definitely gonna happen too
yeah
I guess with like deep fake porn
it uh
uh that's creepy but I guess someone
using like you know find find me this
person yeah I guess you can kind of do
that now like you can kind of like
Google someone's name but
the idea that you just need a picture of
someone is crazy I mean you yeah like
the the theory there I feel like is you
could upload a picture of someone and
they could be like well
they could analyze their clothing and be
like well because they're wearing this
uh they probably are part of this
demographic who shops at this yeah yeah
because they have this bag they're
probably in this yep in this sort of
like income bracket which means they
probably live in this part of town yep
they probably frequent these places
because that's the same you know what
I'm saying yep I I completely forget
that Google and all these people have
droves of data you know just based on
shopping habits yeah so absurd man